One of the most popular sports in Mexico,
it's a phenomenon:
is Lucha Libre.
I wanna participate.
I wanna become a luchador, so I'm asking a terriic luchador,
Cassandro, to help me out.
Cassandro, thank you so much.
(audience applause)
It's important if I'm a luchador,
that I have a character.
Normally when we do this, our gears,
it represents a part of us.
So whatever I wear must represent who I really am,
or a part of my true character.
Yeah, because if you lose your mask, you're done for life.
Oh, if I'm unmasked,
then my career is over?
Well, if you're cute, you can get a second breath of air.
You say if you're cute;
imagine my mask was pulled off
and this face was revealed,
is my career over?
Ooh La La.
(audience cheers)
Oh, my goodness gracious.
Behold!
El Callo Loco!
(audience cheers)
(Conan crows)
(audience screams)
(audience laughs)
I peck at you.
I peck at your eye.
(audience laughs)
[Crows] And then leap.
Right, then I fight my opponent.
[Grunts]
(audience laughs)
(audience screams)
(audience cheers)
(yells and grunts)
(wrestlers grunt)
1! 2! 3!
I peck at your eyes.
[Crows]
Fringe got in my mouth.
(audience laughs)
Okay I've defeated many of your best fighters.
I think it's time that I toured Mexico
with a partner.
What do you think?
You need a tag team partner.
Tag team partner?
I brought one, in America he's known as Andy Richter,
(audience cheers)
In Mexico, he's
El Bebé Malo!
(audience screams)
(majestic music plays)
(El Bebé cries)
El Bebé tell us about your character.
What's the whole idea behind El Bebé Malo?
Well, what kind of person would hit a baby?
Yeah.
You would hit a baby?
Of course.
(slaps)
(audience jeers)
Aw!
[Cries]
Leave him alone, he's just a baby!
A baby's on the floor, crying and defenseless,
and you struck him.
What is he doing inside the ring?
He wandered in, his mama wasn't looking.
My mama drinks.
(audience cheers)
(luchadors yell)
(slow motion sounds)
(wrestlers grunt)
Get back!
[Crows]
I peck at you!
(audience cheers)
(audience applause)